[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spider-man
and after Avengers endgame failed to top
a batons box office first time Marvel
have begun doing whatever it takes to
become highest-grossing movie of all
time with the new footage for the film
finally here I thought I'd break down
everything that you need to know about
it as well as whether I think it's worth
going to the cinema or not to re-watch
the movie there will of course be heavy
spoilers here so if you don't want to
know anything about the film then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video I
hope you enjoy it now sit back relax and
let's get into my breakdown of the New
Avengers and game footage okay so first
things first the initial scene is a
tribute to Stan Lee and it's a real
tear-jerking send-off that basically
cements the icon as the best comic book
creator of all time Stan was no stranger
to the Marvel movies and it's a sort of
recap of his entire time in the MCU and
how his characters have gone on to
become legends that grossed billions of
billions of dollars at the box office
it's a really touching memorial piece
for Stan that lasts roughly about two
minutes and it's sort of an appreciation
piece for the media mogul from here we
go to the extra post credits scene
featuring the Hulk there's been some
back-and-forth on this the last couple
of days kind of over what exactly this
would be however the scene just shows
Hulk jumping into a burning building to
save some children while some outlets
have been saying that this teases the
future for the character it's actually a
scene from earlier in the movie that was
deleted and it doesn't build anything
towards phase 4 what's most baffling
about this is that the CGI isn't even
finished on it so you're basically
watching a scene that they didn't have
time to do properly I've decided to
release it in theaters for some reason
to me this was mega disappointing as I
was expecting some big reveal or
character growth or just you know
something of actual importance but this
massively disappointing scene kind of
confirms to me that Marvel were really
just after a cash
the film and that they didn't want to
spend any more money themselves in order
to get over the mark they couldn't live
with their failure so where has that
brought them back to theatres I'm sorry
I'm sorry that that job was terrible
originally it was speculated that the
new footage would sent her around Tony
Stockman Morgan played by none other
than Catherine Langford
however this rumor is indeed false and
yet that would have been an amazing
scene that scene wasn't screenings for
the film and took place just after Tony
Stark completed the snap that wiped out
Thanos his forces and similar to Thanos
upon carrying it out stark went to the
soul stone and in conversation with his
daughter was told that it was worth it
however those who had to provide
feedback on the film in order for it to
get its final cut said that some may
find that seem confusing and thus it was
removed however now I think that people
have watched the film and have had time
to take it in that scene would have went
over a lot better and probably should
have been included in this rerelease we
also had some rumors that it would show
the melding of Hulk and bana in the
gamma chamber to create professor Hulk
but even this was missing which is a bit
of a letdown for me finally there's a
far from home preview that lasts roughly
for 45 seconds and again it's pretty
underwhelming it's probably about 30
seconds of new footage in it but nothing
that really has the wow factor and then
it just cuts to a trailer of things that
we've already seen before so all-in-all
yeah pretty disappointing if you've been
following the channel and you'll
obviously know I'm a big Marvel fan and
probably buy it
PACA tampons if they had Iron Man's face
stuck on them but this was just a
massive massive letdown especially with
all the hype that was around the film it
just doesn't seem like they were trying
all that hard for this release and I'm
just happy putting in something that
will make fans curious enough to go back
to the cinema but not enough to really
warrant a secondary visit or take any
real time on Disney's part this is sort
of the movie equivalent for me and when
Theresa May kept bringing her brexit
deal back to the Commons only he gets
shut down again and again and I know my
British people can relate to that and
when the movie clocks in at 3 hours
already that you have to sit through
before seeing this it just seems kind of
yeah dull I get that avatar also did a
rerelease but come on I don't really
think anyone could deny that this is
pretty disappointing actually did a poll
yesterday asking whether subscribers of
this channel we're going to see endgame
and we currently set a 52% - yes - 48%
no and now that the footage is out and
obviously loved hear your thoughts on
whether this video has changed your mind
or not or if he's still going I just
want to give a huge thank you to all
1,700 of you that voted and make sure
you leave your thoughts on the entire
scene in the comments below if you
enjoyed this video and if you feel like
it's saved you some money click the
thumbs up button and if you want to see
more Marvel stuff and don't mind how
many things spoiled that make sure you
check out my post credit scene breakdown
I'm spider-man far from home which would
be linked at the end it contains both
the app to credit scenes of the movie so
it's definitely worth watching if you
want to know more I'll leave that linked
at the end and I'll hopefully see you
over there but if not have a great
weekend
Cheers this is a channel for people who
are super into superheroes so if that's
the kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you be the best and
I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you